by the end of 1923 Hitler sees it as his
chance to seize power in Germany and it
he's getting this popularity the Nazis
are getting this followership because
the Weimar Republic is falling apart you
have the hyperinflation the the German
people feel insulted by this French
occupation of the Ruhr region and it
isn't just regular people who are
starting to support the Nazis it's at
very notable people as well this right
over here is general Ludendorff we've
already talked about him is one of the
believers and the stab-in-the-back
theory that Germany would have won World
War one if it wasn't stabbed in the back
by the November criminals who had taken
control of the government during the
revolution in October and November he
becomes a supporter of Hitler as well in
1922 you have Mussolini come to power
this inspires Hitler so as we get into
November Hitler sees this as his chance
and the way that he wants to take
control is he wants to abduct or kidnap
the leaders of the Bavarian region and
there's three of them in particular at
this time and then from there try to
take control of the nation as a whole
and so in November of 1923 you have a
gathering of the three gentlemen who who
are essentially in charge of Bavaria a
gathering of them and several thousand
officials in Bavaria at a local beer
hall in Munich at a beer hall and Hitler
sees this as the the opportunity to take
control so this is where he lost his
launches his Beer Hall Putsch
and I know I'm mispronouncing it but
pooched literally means coup d'etat to
try to overthrow the government and so
Hitler and his Nazis they go to that
beer hall meeting of the government
officials they surround it with their
paramilitary group their stormtroopers
Hitler enters into the hall gets on
stage shoots into the air twice and says
look this is the revolution it is
beginning he forces the three leaders of
Bavaria at gunpoint
to pledge allegiance to the Nazi Party
into this pooched and to Hitler in
particular but then things start to go a
little bit get a little bit start to
start to dissolve as Hitler tries to
address some issues that are go
going on outside the the members who are
who they were going to kidnap are
allowed to leave you have chaos in the
area amongst the Nazis and frankly
amongst the government throughout that
evening into that morning at which point
Hitler and his followers in Ludendorff
is one of them decide to March decide to
march into seven into central Munich all
of this is happening all of this is
happening in Munich which is in Bavaria
they decide to march and during that
March that they have a confrontation
with the official government troops and
it's unclear who fired the first shot
but you do have an exchange of fire and
during that exchange of fire I've seen
estimates about 14 to 16 Nazis are shot
a few days later and a few policemen are
or a few of soldiers are shot as well
and then a few days later Hitler is
arrested Hitler Hitler is arrested he's
tried in early 1924 and then he is
sentenced to jail so all of his all of
his ambitions were kind of led to
nothing but in jail he still continued
to develop his philosophy and he
actually started to continue to develop
his following so he spent most of
roughly the second 2/3 of 1924 in 1924
he spent it in jail 1924 was spent
primarily in jail but while he was in
jail he dictated his autobiography and
his frankly his belief system in mind
Kumpf
which literally means my struggle and
it's actually banned in many countries
it's not banned in the US but it does
make for interesting reading because you
get a sense for on one level how bizarre
hitler's brain was and how disturbed
hitler's brain was but on the other side
you can appreciate that he was he was a
very he was a strong communicator even
even before any of this people would
talk about how transfixing his eyes were
how much attention people paid to him
when he would give a speech but you can
even see this in his writing and you can
do a web search on it you can get the
tire texts of mine comp and it's it's
it's it's disturbing and fascinating at
the same time but this is a little
passage and in this passage it kind of
it gives you an idea of Hitler's view of
why Germany was having these failures
and what he and his and his bizarrely
disturbed mind thought what the solution
was if we pass all the causes of the
German collapse and review the ultimate
and most decisive remains the failure to
recognize the racial problem and
especially the Jewish Menace so he's
blaming all of Hitler's difficulties on
race on a racial problem and in
particular on Jews the defeats on the
battlefield in August 1918 would have
been child's play to bear they stood in
no proportion to the victories of our
people it was not they that caused our
downfall no it was brought about by that
power which prepared these defeats by
systematically over many decades robbing
our people of the political and moral
instincts and forces which alone make
nations capable and hence worthy of
existence and if you read a lot of the
other texts what he's talking about is
this decades of essentially watering
down their society watering down their
society with other people if they didn't
water it down they say the the defeats
in the battlefield would have been
child's play to bear in heedlessly
ignoring the question of the
preservation of the racial foundations
of our nation the old Reich disregarded
the soul right which gives life in this
world so he fused this racial and his
mind racial impurity as the reason why
Hitler was in or what the reason why
Germany was was facing all of this
difficulty and as we'll see over the
next few videos this leads to this leads
to one of the ugliest and bloodiest
periods of human history